the thing is is that like i'm also
working every day but also
you know making content for the anime
man channel is not the only thing i do
now
you know i have like trash taste and i
have like my other hobbies that i want
to
you know you've been everywhere the last
few months yeah like you've collabed
with like everyone and their mum
over the last three months pretty much
joey again all right joey there
yeah even in my videos he's there yeah
everywhere
yeah so yeah so many people are like i
think i think
there was one week where you uploaded an
episode of joining across japan
and then i was i i also did a video on
the same day as well
yeah yeah and people like how is he at
home filming with
jack when he's on a road trip with chris
right now
how is he doing it did he like go back
home quickly and then like
join up again with chris
yeah yeah i i would like to get more
collabs into my content
that's another new year's resolution i
want to make i want to shift my content
that's more
friendly for collabs because like i
don't think i've
i think i've done one collab in my life
um and that's been pretty much it for my
entire time on youtube and that's just
because
my content doesn't really lend well for
collabs because
the only the only way i could collab
with fight is like if i could have like
a guest reviewer and
like the what i think when i see guest
reviewer is like remember those like all
that guy with the glasses
i hate that review collabs away it's
just like hey here's an expert on the
subject and it would be like the most
awkward scripted joke to introduce them
and then they're not as charismatic and
it's yeah well i kind of
i've made those videos back in my day
where like when i had like more of like
the
scripted like rant type of videos yeah i
would always have like a friend of mine
come in being like
what are you doing here
i'm here to talk about it it's it's just
so
not it's what is that that's what that
was literally what it was like how did
this man get a youtube channel
how did he make it grow that's what i
wanted it was like it was the most like
unnatural like
guy fierious like i'm here now
let's talk about whatever you know the
worst parts the worst the worst ones
were when it was scripted as if you both
didn't know you were going to be in this
video
you know what i mean yeah it's the whoa
what are you doing here type of thing
you can make that funny but when it's
like a scripted type of like discussion
based video
there is no natural way to write that in
a script
i've always found it awkward and cringey
as [ __ ] yeah and that's why i stopped
doing it because i
look back at those videos i'm like oh
that was a mistake right i shouldn't
have done that
and i guess like i've been in plenty of
collabs this year and i kind of realized
ah this is this is kind of fun i want to
do this i'm the same i
i didn't really collab much if you were
the first person i did a collab with
them the original journey across japan
oh yeah
and you've got a bit of hate for it yeah
because like you know at first your
viewers are like
who's this person your videos they've
kind of broken into the world right they
always feel like it's nice
especially when it's another youtuber
yeah another youtuber but this time
there's nothing like that everyone loved
you
because it's been accepted and i do
quite like doing
collabs now it's quite fun yeah you just
have to find the balance of course you
have the right you have to find the
right
the right situation yeah yeah sometimes
like you take a look at uh
sometimes like i've done so many collabs
in my time where i've kind of figured
out like
just because you're friends with a
particular youtuber and just because you
guys can you know
supposedly talk about whatever in your
off time it doesn't necessarily mean
that they can be
in any video you want on there yeah and
i typically wait until i've known that
person
like a year old yeah yeah exactly you've
got another a year [ __ ] chris
i've got i've got a calendar on my wall
which is countdown to collab with chris
maybe a new year's resolution for 2022.
your new resolution for 2021 is get
friendly with chris you also at the end
of the day it's kind of awkward right if
uh like you bring a
non-stop bunch of guests off and what if
they're just more entertaining than you
they're like like constantly like every
single guest
everything right it's like that's the
other thing like you if you hang out
with a person enough and that you know
you especially work in the same field
you kind of get the idea of like okay
this is their video right yeah like you
can't outrun
it's like a unspoken etiquette right i
mean like i'm not gonna like you know
because i did my best to not you know
[ __ ] take too much of the spotlight
away from chris because i'm like my
spotlight because i'm like this is crazy
like i understand this is chris's
channel this is his show so i was like
that in your video when you did the
capsule hotel
yeah right shipping container yeah and i
was just like i'll just because you're
swagging the hammer you just kind of
like follow you kind of follow their
lead right because
they're going to do the over-the-top
intro or whatever yeah right right so
like you kind of just have to learn that
through
experience you just got to be the you
just got to like
be subscribed be the dog that you are
i'm
[Music]
go oh your place yes dear
shall we get naked in the bat now we're
doing a shot
and you're going to like it that's kind
of like what it was
a thousand-year-old where is he
yeah i don't know like i i also want to
i also want to keep doing collabs as
well but i kind of again you're the
collab king
yeah i look at it i look at it
supposedly people i know have done
collaborations with more youtube you all
like
probably done it more than anyone yeah
who doesn't
say no right i i don't know i just i
don't know i just have like
uh i i feel there's like a totally
different quality of doing a collab
regardless of what the content might be
right
like in my opinion if someone told me
okay you can make a youtube channel and
you can have all these millions of
subscribers with millions of views
but you can't collab with anyone right i
kind of be like what's the point that's
[ __ ] lie
that's a [ __ ] off because
[Laughter]
if i did it like legit like if i did an
entire year worth of content
just by myself it wouldn't be fun i
would be like it's not fun but
i'm still getting paid [ __ ] it i'll do
it i'm going to be honest
the suck is hitting and i don't know why
we gotta finish the ball
it's uh it's delicious what can i say
nearly finished it's like it's like
drinking [ __ ] paint cleaner
straight from the barrel it shouldn't
just be you connor shouldn't have had
that yeah
if you want to be friends with chris
chris probably
you probably bought too much and you
were like [ __ ] let's unload one on the
boys
[Music]
i know i know you have the british
mindset i know how it is with gifts and
ours come on
it's a last minute thing and you're like
oh [ __ ] it over twelve dollars
i'll pay you twelve dollars to not bring
it next time
send it back to get me something else
get me a lineup
okay then like who saved like gone uh
chris like who is like
other than the people you already know
who is a youtuber that you would want to
probably collab with the most
well i mean chris you have to say my
name that quickly i mean come on
it's a really difficult question i don't
like is there a title or like maybe not
a particular person but like is there a
type of youtuber susan
maybe
your biggest fan yeah i saw that i
couldn't believe it that was really
weird that was surreal that
i couldn't believe that either and also
youtube the actual official youtube
channel commented on our video
when we saw mount fuji saying
congratulations oh was that on our video
i don't even know youtube had an
official
i thought it was the fukushima video
that they commented them no they
commented on
us oh no that was yeah that was susan
but yeah yeah youtube official channel
and we saw a fuji like well done lads
and i was like is that someone hell yeah
youtube has an official channel with 35
million subscribers
good luck thanks youtube thank you now
stop demonetizing my content
yeah i don't know who i'd want to collab
with i i feel like if i knew who i
wanted to collab with
i i didn't understand by now yeah i'd
like i i need to figure out what
what content i would want to do first
because
the thing i hate the most is seeing
collab content that's
obviously like very forced collab
content
desperate um like in your in your recent
one
it makes sense to have someone else
there to play off of right and yeah
sorry
yeah i'm right here this guy i mean
joseph unfortunately i i refuse to say
his name since uh he took my spot
chris promised his spot for me and then
joey came in and swooped it away i
couldn't believe it the audacity
i've kidding oh you [ __ ] it oh wow
oh it's this wine bottle opener this is
this is the one dollar [ __ ] wine
bottle opener for daiso
oh you didn't need to drink that anyway
oh that's that's the wine out the window
it gives it a more earthy texture anyway
this is good wine as well i [ __ ]
picked this out i used to work at a
castle when i did that an awful lot
but i was serving guests what's
significant about the castle
hold on a second you worked at a castle
or which castle i mentioned
and i served uh prince andrew and elon
musk what
not the same night that would be mental
but like what wait how was
how how is this the first i'm hearing of
this yeah
this is the first time hearing over this
from me pleasing
talking come on i worked at castle and
elon musk which castle
i can't
and i had to bring out his um
rocket-shaped birthday cake and sing him
also have a lightning mcqueen bed at
home
did he rock up with just the biggest
blunt in his hand
well yeah i know yeah he did but
he did he did no definition here oh no
oh
oh oh oh oh no it's breaking
grab it by the hand this is this is so
tense